look at what we
we've seen as it relates to the coaching
search and i love josh mccown this pains
me this pains me to articulate it i've
written about it it was something that
popped up friday late afternoon early
evening that they actually interviewed
josh mccown
who's still a player
right a head coaching position
for for the head coaching position not
quarterback coach not quality control
they interviewed josh mccown who has
never coached at any level above high
school
because remember he was doing that like
part-time right friday he would come in
he he's never coached high-level
football they interviewed him to be the
head coach
of an nfl franchise which again
i love josh mccown it makes a mockery of
the process it's a middle finger to all
the other coaches out there white or
black
who have worked their way up who have
put in their time who are qualified you
know we hear a guy gets hired fritz paul
alliance has no problem with urban meyer
going to jaguars because he's qualified
well there's always going to be a white
coach who's qualified there's always
going to be a black coach who's
qualified the question is who's going to
get the job and when you start
considering white coaches who aren't
qualified that's when people start
saying something stinks well definitely
that that's exactly it and i mean
just the interview alone there oh i'm
with you josh mccown i love him i mean
he's a great guy he really is i played
with his brother luke and tampa bay it's
a great family all together i have no
doubts that josh mccown could one day be
an unbelievable head coach in the nfl i
don't doubt that at all he's a that's a
football family they're all about it but
to just say you can go to quarterback
and then to head coach in the nfl that's
insanity that's stupid and i mean if i'm
deshawn watson and i see that that alone
makes me go what what do we talk we
weren't going to interview eric the
enemy but we brought in josh mccown what
like what are we doing and that's why
houston's gotta watch out i mean you're
never gonna have this problem because of
the salary cap and free agency in the
nfl but man i i guarantee if you talk to
most of the league they're going to go i
don't really want to play for the
houston texans i'm going to try to avoid
that franchise
and i don't fault josh mccown for doing
definitely not not his fault hey hey you
know what if nothing else you learned
to see what it goes like maybe some
point down the road i'll have a real
chance to be a head coach exactly i
fought the texans
it's an affront
to the process it's an insult to all of
the folks out there who are qualified
right now to be head coaches and when
you consider
they initially didn't seek permission to
interview eric b enemy
until they eventually did after it was
obvious deshaun watson wasn't happy
about it and then they completely
ignored even talking to robert salad do
a 90-minute zoom with robert sala what
do you got to lose 90 minutes it's 90
minutes talk to the guy see what you
think of it maybe you go into thinking
well yeah he's really not our guy well
hey he's our guy you never know until
you talk to him and and to to interview
someone who no one else has even
discussed has even mentioned his name
hasn't come up to be hired by anybody on
a staff much less as a head coach and
again
and jo i think josh josh is smart enough
to understand where we're coming from
he's just the guy who's the pawn in all
of this and he got out of it the benefit
but i think he's smart enough to realize
there was going to be some blow back for
this because it's just asinine and it is
an insult to all qualified candidates
out there regardless of background
regardless of race it's an insult to
them that someone who is completely
unqualified got an interview but but
chris hey when you have somebody
completely unqualified who's running the
team this is the kind of stuff that
happens
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports